ce jeudi aux côtés d'autres
organisations syndicales la cgt appelle
à une grande journée de mobilisation les
syndicats étudiants des différentes
villes de france ont également décidé de
rejoindre ce mouvement à paris le rendez
vous est donné à 14 heures place de la
république pour se terminer à nation
d'autres villes de l'hexagone accueille
également des manifestations telles que
marseille toulouse ou encore bordeaux
objectif donner de la voix à toutes les
professions de france
plusieurs revendications sont sur la
table les organisations syndicales
revendiquent avant tout une
revalorisation des salaires
au coeur de leurs revendications
l'emploi et les conditions de travail
les syndicats réclament entre autres la
semaine de travail à 32 heures
l'abandon définitif de la réforme des
retraites ou encore le renforcement de
la sécurité sociale cette mobilisation
est la première organisée depuis
l'annnonce de l'exécutif du plan de
relance de 100 milliards d'euros
reste à savoir comment seront prises en
compte les différentes restrictions lors
de ces manifestations
certains syndicats notamment la cfdt ont
préféré une pas se joindre au mouvement
jugeant qu'il était trop tôt pour
organiser quelque chose en commun en
septembre